get on point get on point now there's
coaching strategy and so much intensity
copy copy copy yeah i feel like an
athlete and that's that's what i
consider myself as a
as an esport athlete we do coaching we
we have practices we do like what we do
in like any other sports is just
on a computer i think as technology
grows um and advances that esports will
also advance
and it will become
bigger than sports running esports as a
pilot event alongside the commonwealth
games in birmingham this summer brings
the skill of a virtual kill
into a traditional sporting arena we're
now able to kind of
celebrate it and shout about it and say
yes this is real you know please take us
seriously now
kind of thing so i do see a lot of
positives in terms of the growth of
esports in the uk
the summer olympics now have
skateboarding and sport climbing both
are now reaching new audiences because
of it and at the winter games new events
like big air are proving inspirational
sport has to keep moving to keep
relevant and what gaming might not be
full-on physical exertion it can leave
you just as exhausted as a session on
the slopes
we do see other sports like snooker and
darts and even though there's a finesse
in the movement um there's a lot of
mental agility required so i'm
interested to see what it brings
the big gaming tournaments already
attract huge prize money but for ruby
who won silver for great britain in last
year's global esports games a new
platform changes so much parents will
read it and talk to their kids and see
that their them playing video games
might not just be wasting their lives or
you know spending time inside when they
could be out doing you know regular
sports um and from that we'll start to
see more careers we'll see more talent
developing in the uk in all of our games
and eventually you know the uk could be
at the forefront of of esports he's
gonna pass the angle
[Applause]
will do the job
again
some purists may not like it but the
scale of what's happening online means
esports are ready to go mainstream
tom parmenter sky news